Hey there.
This is Jason Guts and you're listening
to think again.
A big thank podcast
since 2008 I think has been bringing you
the big ideas in little doses from some
of the most creative thinkers around.
On the thing again,
podcast,
we step outside of our comfort zone,
surprising our guests and me,
your host with unexpected clips from big
things,
synergy you,
archives,
ideas that we didn't necessarily come
here prepared to discuss.
This is the fourth mix tape that I'm
doing of some of the highlights of the
first year of the show and just time to
reflect back and think about where we've
been.
As you may have noticed if you're
following the show,
I have a lot of creative writers on.
I'm a writer myself and I think a lot
about the craft of writing and some of
the guests have given our listeners
advice that I find incredibly powerful
and that stays with me all the time.
This episode is an attempt to round up
some of those best moments from those
most powerful moments.
Advice about writer's block,
how to work with the creative team,
how to deal with success and failure and
how to deal with the psychology of being
a writer.
I hope that you'll find these moments as
meaningful as I do.
This first segment is from a
conversation with the acclaimed
playwright and screenwriter,
Sir David Hare.
He really surprised me.
There was a really interesting and
unexpected turn in the middle of this
conversation that I found delightful and
the surprise quip is with Sheila keen
talking about the psychology of happened
happiness.
If you look at the neuroscience,
the way that we're wired has a profound
effect on how we hear and respond to
feedback.
We took a look at three variables that
are particularly important in terms of
your reaction to feedback.
The first is your baseline.
It's sort of how happy or unhappy are
you in the absence of other events in
your life.
Where's that level that you come back
to?
It's a scale of one to 10 some people
just live their lives at nine right
there,
just so unbelievably happy and cheerful
about everything.
This research comes from looking at
lottery winners a year later.
They're about as happy or unhappy as
they were before they won the lottery.
And people who go to jail a year later,
they're about as happy or unhappy as
before they went to jail.
Now we look at the second variable,
which is swing.
When you get positive or negative
feedback,
how far off your baseline does it knock
you?
The same piece of feedback can be
devastating for one person and you know,
kind of annoying for another.
And then the third variable is how long
does it take you to come back to your
baseline?
How long do you sustain positive feeling
or how long does it take you to recover
from negative feeling so taken together.
That's where the big variation in
sensitivity comes from.
That some people are extremely sensitive
and other people are pretty insensitive.
Um,
or maybe I should
say even keel,
but I suppose if you're insensitive,
you don't really care what I call you,
so it doesn't matter.
So there's a lot in there.
Well,
there are two principle things,
yes.
About what she's saying,
the feedback thing.
Um,
I work in the collaborative arts.
I choose to be a playwright rather than
a novelist or a poet.
And therefore for me,
collaboration is absolutely essential.
If I'm working on a movie set or if I'm
in a rehearsal,
then the whole day what I have written
is put under a degree of scrutiny and
the actors in particular will say to me,
you think that in the interest of the
general story,
you have achieved this scene.
But let me tell you from my point of
view,
playing it as one person in this scene,
there is not enough for me here.
I haven't got what I want or I can't
make sense of this change to which I can
only respond either by arguing or going
back and rewriting in order that the
woman or man who's playing this
particular part will fit into the
general picture and be able to play what
they want to play.
In other words,
they're going to put it under a scrutiny
that maybe you have overlooked in your
rush to follow the main narrative
through.
And so you're making adjustments all the
time and you're accepting feedback.
My experience is you can do that from a
position of confidence.
In other words,
if you're confident about what the
general movement of the play or film is,
then there is no end to the amount of
input that you're open to because you
know that it will not be destructive
because you know that the resilience of
the basic idea of what you're doing,
we'll see you through and the thing
can't be damaged by minor adjustments.
And if you're working with great actors,
as I've spent my life working with some
of the greatest actors in the world,
you're just crazy not to listen to them
because what they're going to bring to
it is going to be incredibly useful to
you.
So from that point of view,
feedback is what I live on.
That's,
that's my element and opinion.
Remember is the element that any
creative person has to swim in.
In other words,
you know,
a play doesn't exist until it's put
before an audience.
And what the audience's opinion is,
is what finishes that play off.
You know when you,
when people want to become actors,
young people,
I say to them,
you think you're going out there and
you're going to create other people,
it's going to be creative.
I said half your job is going to be
being judged.
How?
If your job is going to be out there and
sensing that the audience don't like
you,
are you up for that?
Do you have the kind of temperament that
is going to be able to cope with the
dislike of large numbers of people?
You're going to fail in certain roles
and when you fail in certain roles in
front of people,
it's going to be deeply embarrassing.
Shaming,
humiliating and upsetting.
Are you up for that?
Are you up for being judged?
And that's what working in the
collaborative arts involves.
Well,
let me ask you this because I understand
from your memoir and just from the way
you write that you're a sensitive
person.
You know you are a very sensitive
So when you were just starting out as a
playwright,
you know,
if somebody had said that to you,
if somebody had come and said like,
do you have what it takes?
Is your skin thick enough?
Would you have recoiled in horror and
crawled into a corner?
Completely.
I,
I would.
I would not have chosen this job.
I had known the degree of judgment that
it would involve.
I have sat in audiences where the
audience is rejected the play and did
not want to hear what I wanted to say to
them and an extremely pay.
It ripped my soul out.
It was a night in Seattle where a film
of mine was laughed off the screen in
1987 with a test audience to a preview
audience.
I will never go back to the city of
Seattle,
but listen in the,
in the time available to us.
Let's go back to her other point,
which is really interesting.
The happiness thing.
You know that a year later the person
who is in jail,
is that the same level of happiness that
they were before they were in Joe,
I'm afraid.
I think this is true.
When you're young,
you have a fantasy that you can change
and that you can change your life and
you will achieve something and then when
you achieve that thing,
that will make a significant difference
to your contentment index.
In other words,
you're driven by fantasy.
When you're my age,
there is no fantasy left.
You know,
I am extremely happily married to a
completely wonderful woman whom I
absolutely adore.
My children I adore.
Therefore,
my private life could not be any happier
than says there is no fantasy about my,
I do not go to sleep dreaming of meeting
some other woman who will transform my
life.
I adore the person that I am with and
can imagine no better do you see,
nor will I do.
I dream of writing a hit to play.
I've written hip place.
I know what it feels like.
I've lived through it.
It doesn't significantly change your
life.
You still have to start again and try
and write the next one.
So I feel that what she says about how
the sort of basic level of happiness you
have in your life,
it doesn't really change very much.
One of my favorite conversations was
with Turkeys,
arguably in most celebrated living
novelist or Han Pamuk who won the Nobel
Prize for literature.
Here he's talking about something I've
never really heard a writer discussed
before,
which is the psychology of sitting down
every day to write and how a creative
writer should manage that.
I find this to be incredible advice and
the surprise clip is from psychologist
Bessel Vanderkolk on trauma.
Okay.
Psychiatry has always had a complex
relationship to trauma.
It started who started off as a
discipline that looked at way back in
the late 18 hundreds people have very
bizarre reactions to trauma and so
there's that define hysteria,
sort of a some interested and then they
put it Kubashen.
It's people no longer a large studies
theory.
First World War breaks out a huge number
of charm.
It has guys probably had lots to do with
the rise of Nazism.
And then in 1947 the last book about war
charm,
it gets published and there's nothing
til 1982 or something.
So it takes a long time.
Very psychiatry really doesn't want to
see trauma.
And in the current Dsm,
the people called the Bible of
Psychiatry,
now we live with via diagnoses like
oppositional defiant disorder where
people don't ask,
why did this kids come become defiance?
Bipolar disorder cause being mentally
unstable going up and down at the
emotions and psychiatry does video what
to look at,
what's behind there.
And as a consequence,
the,
instead of looking at social conditions
as being at the origin of these
disorders,
uh,
these kids get dragged up last year in
the u s kids got 18 point $1 billion
versus secretary we drugs and these
drugs do calm people down.
But they also work on the reward system
in the brain and decrease curiosity,
openness,
experimentation,
engagement with people.
So the neglect of the issue of trauma in
the u s in particular is a very serious
public health issue.
For me,
the biggest traumas of life is of course
unrequited love.
My Normal Museum of innocence is
extensively about the illusions of flow.
I chronicle upper middle class,
Turkish men's obsession infatuation.
It is twice removed.
Cousin,
just like a trauma,
he can never get out of it.
He's ridiculed and made fun of,
and a trauma means you are almost in a
war.
Your panic,
you don't know what to do.
You want to survive and you lack that
sense of logic that will control and
heal you and perhaps paved the way out
of a traumatic situation.
My understanding of a trauma is that you
want to get out of a situation,
but yet you're so much pressure that
your mind does not give you the clue out
of that kafkaesque way out of that
problem.
Lau is like that.
Perhaps psychology psychiatrist should
focus about Lao treated as that trauma.
I am against all this glorification,
sugar rising,
put them on a pedestal.
The idea of love is a sweetie.
I agree.
It's the sweetest thing,
but it all comes with a bad package of
trauma,
longing,
jealousy,
anger,
miscommunication,
self obsession,
making you not see the whole picture.
I'm a writer in,
I want to be,
I'm a self conscious writer,
a writer who wants to know the effects
of what he or she is doing,
but also there is one side to me that
makes me survive.
Perhaps that is letting things go and
just following the music that is
spontaneously coming inside of me.
Colors,
notes,
verge that I'm possessed with Indian.
If you write every day like me,
sit on a table everyday traumas and
vanish perhaps because I know that life
will be hard if I brought working in an
office.
I choose the life of the solitary artist
writing every day,
which avoids me from the pressures and
traumas of everyday life,
but it's inimitable.
Life is in the end.
Daily life.
I mean you are working hard.
You create a structure,
you sit down every day,
you have a discipline,
so somehow those structures are
sufficient.
Then you don't have to worry as much
about trying to control the rest.
I argued that a creative writer
professor should teach more about this
than what should be the plot.
What should be the,
because normative structural policies
about writing fiction is less important
than teaching.
The would be writer,
how to behave in life,
how to take easy,
the regular systematic traumas,
writing blogs,
unhappiness,
money,
happiness,
and depressive slowing down.
Being a writer is more about minding
your mental health,
navigating according to your moods,
what section chapter of the book you
should write first because it's
appropriate to your moods now,
what to do when you're blocked and how
to skip one chapter,
skip one trauma,
skip one problem and continue.
I understand that psychiatry address
traumas I taught,
they were already doing that.
I taught by the people we're going to
people and paying money and because they
had traumas.
Now I learned they go for other reasons.
I would go to a psychiatrist because I
had a trauma.
If I were to fall in love and never get
out of Logan field that I'm hurt or if
I'm blocked by my writing and feel that
I'm scared of something.
I had traumas,
political representative traumas.
In the past.
In the end they gave me nightmares,
but the long run,
they just pass away.
If you are busy with something that
makes you happy and it writing,
writing,
Oh yes,
gave me lots of problems.
But in the long run,
I achievement of finishing something and
being like a child,
playing with his toys,
being busy with all the time,
sols,
all the traumas of two worlds.
I want to ask you like when you sit down
and your brain isn't working that day,
does that happen?
Whenever,
boy,
then what do you do?
Hemingway has a nice advice.
He said at the end of today,
if you know what you're going to write,
don't write the last sentence.
Keep it for the next morning.
So start with that sentence.
Once you write a beautiful sentence,
that sentence will tell you what will be
the next,
what will be the next,
what will be the next?
When you're writing fiction,
if you're in it eight sentence,
you have a magic feeling that it's
unfolding on his own.
You look a lot of your window.
You look at say New York silhouette or
Bosphorus that I see from my window and
my mind as if processed because I'm so
deeply in it.
You continue like that.
Eh?
I think if you work three hours a day,
if you write three pages,
if you work nine hours a day,
you write not nine pages but 18 pages.
Once creativity goes up exponentially,
once you devote your life whole life to
it,
even your sleep to it.
The way to get out of our traumas in
fact is to invent a second world fictive
world or artistic world that will avoid
the trauma,
but perhaps going to a psychiatrist who
understands you,
maybe something,
but then maybe you can try it anymore.
Yes.
This is the thing that my friends always
tell me or and I see you're traumatized.
I can give you this pill,
but maybe tomorrow are feel happy and
that you cannot write again.
Is that sent through contradiction in my
life?
Perhaps because I'm happy I cannot write
perhaps because I'm so unhappy I can
write.
These are reasonable contradictions.
I think a writer's life has all of these
variations,
but in the end,
sailing with good Ville and bleeding in
the wind is the essential and you sell
on and on and on and on,
and I'm writing fiction for the last 40
years.
After 40 years of sailing,
I have a sense that this wind will take
me a twit.
Nice,
quiet,
good,
beautiful place.
I trust them in and sail and sail and
right then right
earlier this year,
I sat down with author James McBride,
who won the book award
for the color of water to talk to him
about his memoir or biography
investigation into the life of James
Brown.
Here.
He brings up his recent experiences in
what must have been one of the most
interesting writers rooms ever.
The surprise quip is from journalists,
Charles Duhigg,
who wrote the power of habit talking
here about creative teams.
About five years ago,
Google started this interesting
experiment.
They wanted to figure out how to build
the perfect team and so what they did is
they started collecting huge amounts of
data about all the teams within Google.
The teams that at a glance look most
productive oftentimes aren't.
But if you can create this
conversational turn taking equality of
voices,
if you can convince people to really
listen to each other by being sensitive
to the nonverbal cues were giving off,
then you create psychological safety and
psychological safety is the single
greatest determinant in whether a team
comes together or whether it falls
apart.
One of my favorite examples of
psychological safety and a team really
come to coming together is the early
days of Saturday night live.
So when you think about it on Saturday
night live,
never should have worked,
right?
You have a bunch of Comedians who are
kind of misanthropes to begin with,
and yet for some reason when Lauren
michaels put them in a room together,
everyone was willing to kind of get
along.
They,
they were willing to put aside their ego
and create this amazing show together.
Not only an amazing show,
but a show that was put together under
these incredible time pressures,
right?
They have a week to put together a live
show.
And when I talked to the early writers
and performers on Saturday night live
and I asked them why this happened.
All of them said the same thing because
of Lorne michaels.
So Lauren Michaels has this very unique
way of running meetings.
He sits down and the meeting starts and
what he'll do is he'll make everyone go
around the table and say something,
and if someone hasn't spoken up in a
little while,
Lauren michaels will actually stop the
meeting and he'll say,
Susie,
I noticed that you haven't chimed in.
Like what are you thinking about right
now?
And it all works out,
but it's because he creates an
environment that feels safe,
where everyone feels like they can speak
up and they feel like everyone else is
genuinely listening to them because
they're sensitive to all the cues that
they're sending.
I think that kind of analysis is a dream
killer for me because I think when you
analyze stuff too much you,
the next thing you know it's like,
you know,
analyzing sex.
I mean we should we write a report when
we're done check lists of,
you know,
two phones,
one to five.
How did you,
how was it?
I mean,
yeah,
I,
I think that kind of thinking is
dangerous for the creative process.
Like if you come in with that method and
no,
I mean,
whatever method of following.
No.
Yeah,
I wouldn't,
I mean,
look,
I wouldn't fall,
what's his name?
Lorne.
Lorne michaels.
I wouldn't find his method.
I'd follow my method.
Everybody has a different solar as
different way of singing that song.
I think the collaborative process,
which is really what the journalist is
talking about is dictated by what you
need to create and who's in the room.
And so that process works for that
particular group of people given the
time constraints that exist.
I don't know that that would work.
If you are writing for a six part mini
series like I did.
Uh,
I was one of the writers in a six part
mini series for David Simon and
creative.
The wire has an area that's called the
parting the waters.
It's about Taylor branch is three book
series about the civil rights movement.
I'll be watching myself,
ta-nehisi codes,
tail brands,
David Simon.
Now we're going there.
What was it like being in a writing room
with David Simon and Tanahashi and like
how did that go?
Well,
it was great.
I mean,
uh,
that work.
Like it was free.
I mean,
David didn't point that.
She wouldn't say,
what are you thinking?
You know,
he did it a different way and he said,
uh,
you know,
we have to decide which story we're
going to tell and who's going to tell
it.
He's like,
count base,
you know?
I mean,
he's like Duke Ellington,
me,
like Duke Ellington had a band of great
soloists and he'd say,
this is the composition.
Now put your thing to it.
David is the same way.
You know,
he says this,
these are the parameters.
You're,
you're all small little kings and your
kingdom.
Let's bring our kingdoms together and
see which one of us can come up with the
best idea.
Whoever has the best idea,
we'll run with that.
So you can't bring a lot of ego into a
room like that.
You have to be at,
you're there to serve as a story and a
good writer will serve as the story.
A good musician will serve as the music.
As a novelist,
how do you work?
Do you plot out everything before you
write or,
and you just,
no,
I don't.
I have no standard way of doing it other
than getting up at four o'clock in the
morning and getting to work.
You can,
you can write at four o'clock in the
morning.
Okay,
well I,
I,
you know,
I go to bed at nine all right,
if I go to bed at 11 I get up at four
o'clock anyway.
I'll take a nap at 11:00
AM until,
you know,
I mean,
the discipline of music taught me how
the necessity of practice.
But going back to your earlier statement
about this room full of writers,
if you're a real serious writer,
you,
you are a servant to the story you
writing chooses you,
you don't choose it.
So when you're working with other
writers,
you have to service the idea.
And that's really where craft comes into
the trade shows itself because then you
have to be able to throw left handed in
Bat,
right handed a bat right hand and throw
left handed.
Right?
You have to be able to,
you have to be able to hit a curve ball
in the bottom of the seventh,
two out in guy on base.
You just have to be able to do it
because if you don't,
you bring in the whole team down.
So you have to learn how to play every
position.
You're a person who's collab and you've
done musics and you've collaborated with
other people.
You've done theater.
Tanahashi has written a comic book just
now.
Uh,
you know,
so there's a,
just,
I think of like some of these folks,
you know,
William Faulkner,
the folks like sitting alone in their
room for their whole lives would
probably freak out if they suddenly had
to share the table.
Prob more maybe,
maybe.
I mean,
but I must say that writing is a lonely
life.
And so working with other writers in
this particular situation was just a lot
of fun.
And my problem is that at my age,
you know,
I walk into a room and I started talking
to people get intimidated.
They think that,
you know,
I know what I'm talking about.
You know,
I'm,
I reached the point in my life where I
don't really feel like I'm not,
I stopped working hard at trying to make
people feel comfortable if they can't
accept me on my own terms,
just to,
you know,
they'll see shortly that it's cool and
if they don't,
then there's nothing I,
nothing I write or play or do is going
to make them feel comfortable anyway.
So I didn't have that problem when I was
working with David and Eric overmeyer
tiny he seen and Taylor branch,
right?
They were just cool.
We were all there for the same purpose
and I really liked them all.
And I ended in early,
earlier mix tape with a spontaneous
monologue from one of my favorite
writers,
Howitt and rapper kate tempest.
But the whole conversation with her,
it was incredibly illuminating.
She had just finished her first novel,
the bricks that built the houses.
And here she talks fascinatingly about
writer's block.
The surprise clip is from author
Augusten burroughs.
He's talking about writer's block,
which he believes is a real thing and
we'll see how kate responds to that.
The worst thing to do with writer's
block is kind of like the worst thing to
do with back pain.
You know,
if you have back pain,
you don't want to stay in bed for the
next five years.
You know you need to begin physical
therapy.
You need to maybe do yoga or
[inaudible].
You need to move with writer's block.
You don't stay away from the writing and
think,
I'll wait until the solution comes to me
because that's not how it works for a
writer.
The solution comes to us as we're
writing.
It comes mid sentence.
The solution to writer's block is to
write about the writer's block.
Why don't you have it?
Why does it suck?
Really,
why it could be a case of you knows
you're off plot.
We're off point.
It could be that there's something
deeper,
better,
truer jucier that you really need to
write about that maybe you're too
embarrassed to write.
I'm of the opinion that there is no such
thing as writer's block.
I don't think it exists.
I think that there is the fear of
writing badly.
That's,
that's what it is.
And if you're afraid of writing badly,
then and you're not going to be writing
because it's a,
it's a crippling fear that,
but you just have to take that fear away
from it until you saw the flower.
I love this shit today.
It doesn't matter.
Right?
It doesn't matter if it's good like
because the point of it is right.
Anyone can have an idea anybody but
finishing an ideas what I'm saying?
That's the agony.
That's difficult.
It's always difficult.
It's fucking hard work and apologies for
swearing,
but the point is,
is that like you're,
you're kind of in competition with
yourself already because you're trying
to improve.
You're trying to be better tomorrow than
you were yesterday.
That's one thing.
But having an idea,
beautiful,
perfect.
It's going to be,
you know,
it's going to change the world.
That's going to be the best thing you've
ever done to the actual finished thing
is going to be clunky.
You're going to be ashamed of it.
You're going to pick it apart.
We're getting,
you can't get to sleep.
You're going to hate yourself for doing
it.
That's the point.
That's why you move on and have another
idea.
You finish things,
you finished things.
The stepping stones towards finding your
voice.
It's like on on a writing day.
If I don't feel,
if it's not happening,
if it's not coming out,
I don't,
I don't force it.
I take a walk,
like I stopped,
like I'm in a slightly different
situation because I'm usually,
I'm usually quite up against it with
deadlines.
So I wrote the majority of this has it
fixed,
it built the houses,
kind of what I was on the road.
Sorry.
So in a tour bus full of other people?
Yeah,
and it's all boss or in a cafe or in a
service station or like in the three
days I had off between tours in my
bedroom or whatever it was like,
and the thing is like you can make all
kinds of excuses that you can say,
oh I need some space and I need time and
I need natural light.
And I need a room with a view and I
need,
or you can just,
you know,
you can just finish it.
It's really hard,
but it's what,
it's what will make you better.
Say you don't take a walk and say you
sit down and you make yourself right one
day and it comes out and it's shit.
You delete it.
Do you rewrite it?
It depends what you're working on.
So I feel if I'm working on a play,
you can hear,
you can feel when it's a bad line,
it's suddenly you're like,
what?
Nobody would ever say that about this
character would never say that.
But the thing is when,
when I'm up against the deadline or
usually it's,
I'm under a lot of pressure because of
my schedule because I mean that's the
way I work and I'm happy about it.
It's good for me.
But sometimes there isn't time to be
having an off day and that's like,
it's crazy pressure but it works.
Sometimes it works.
Other times I'm in a really great
situation because writing can be quite
lonely pursuit.
But then when you have an editor or in
music,
I have a great music producer who I work
with or what are making theater or I
have the director,
I worked with a director and there were
these other people,
these kind of midwives that populate a
writer's life that help you to kind of
get over yourself enough to just kind of
deliver it,
you know?
And um,
you know,
with,
with this,
for example,
with the bricks,
the most exhilarating part of this
process was deleting 30,000
words and feeling how good that was.
Like suddenly it got lighter and it kind
of held its shape a bit more
successfully.
And I could just feel this thing that
I'd only ever heard writers talk about,
but I'd never experienced,
which is like the kind of joy of just
cutting,
cutting and just watching it kind of
grow.
Yeah.
Really interesting.
So yeah,
shout out loud as shit.
It'll stay there for a bit and then you
lose it.
It's all right,
you know?
Yeah.
So it sounds like a big part of your
process is kind of the gun to your head,
like just saying,
basically I got to get this done and
putting yourself in a position where
that's the case.
Yeah.
And even before when there wasn't
deadlines,
when I have no publisher or anything
else,
I was still inflicting that kind of
pressure on myself because I've always
felt that time is kind of against me.
I don't know why then if he feel like
that.
Yeah.
Well increasingly,
but uh,
for me it was interesting because I,
I grew up relatively privileged and had
the privilege slash curse of being able
to kind of wander around and like,
it took me longer to feel that the gun
of time to my head.
Yeah.
And I mean,
I don't know much about your background,
but um,
I know from the fact that so much of the
press is about your being from southeast
London and the neighborhood that you
focus on and stuff.
I'm guessing you may be,
didn't have people sending you off to
wander around.
I didn't get some really good supportive
environment,
but the,
the way that south London figures in my
work and then in myself,
it's like,
it's such a huge Paul.
I mean,
because if you grow up in a big city,
especially in a pot in a city that's so
south London,
it,
okay,
so I suppose for an American audience to
kind of say,
oh,
southeastern,
then it probably doesn't mean anything.
Like,
you know,
unless you've spent some time and none
of them,
but the kind of character of it in my
head,
the way that it is a very creative place
in terms of people who are really making
something happen there.
I felt in my,
it's very mixed place culturally,
racially,
and economically,
lots of different people live in very
close together.
There's a certain sensibility that it
gives you if you're from there,
which is,
it's quite a rough area.
It was like the highest,
the highest rates of teenage pregnancy
and murder amongst teenagers when I was
growing up in Lewisham,
which is the borrower,
I'll go up,
but at the same time there's a huge
amount of music and huge amount of
amazing,
vibrant creativity and I found it to be
a really positive place.
I grew up in a very good home.
My Dad was a lawyer,
my mom was a teacher.
We just lived in this area that was like
full of full of life,
you know,
it was just full of life and every time
I walked out of the door and down the
street,
every time I ever went anywhere,
I would pass by thousands if not fucking
tens of thousands of people because it's
London,
it's a big city,
and I just always felt so close to life,
you know,
it was just everywhere.
And that I have a huge love for people
like the rubber,
not so obvious to say,
but I'm really moved by just like being
amongst strangers and feeling connected
to their humanity and feeling this thing
I'm talking about earlier.
What about this kind of current reality
that we are denied access to?
I think there is something about a kind
of a frequency that our rights are
exists on looking for the kind of
looking,
the internal experience of strangers.
You know,
I don't really know why,
but yeah,
I watched somebody walk down the street
and the way that they're carrying their,
their car keys,
something about the way they just
dropped their shopping bag.
Like I feel so blown away by a tiny
movement,
right?
They kind of sends me into this like
deep passion for these people,
you know,
for,
for somebody.
And I think that the writer is
constantly feeling kind of outside of
life,
which is what sends us to the page
often,
you know,
trying to write ourselves into this
existence that we were kind of
constantly because we observed so much I
kind of outside of things.
But the observation is one of like pure
love.
Really.
Yeah.
I got,
I got lost in south London and I found
myself there but you know,
got into all kinds of trouble and all
kinds of like beautiful,
beautiful things happened.
And I still live there and it's still
home.
You know in the book there's,
you talk about gentrification and
there's this sense,
I mean it seems like you feel like the
heart of south London is still intact,
but that there's this threat somehow of
it being co opted or,
yeah.
It's strange because the,
I think it's more helpful because this
conversation about gentrification,
it happens all over the world and it's a
tragedy.
But the minute where I've been thinking
about it is it's more useful actually
need to pan out of this a little bit and
think about what this means it in a kind
of why the framework,
which is this kind of symptomatic greed
and the exploitation of land for profit
above people and this year you could,
okay,
yes,
it's,
it's a real shame shaft on this
changing.
My God,
it hurts.
But if we pan out a little bit and we
think about land,
land is being exploited for profit,
the people that live on that land are
being destroyed.
The community is that culture has been
destroyed.
This isn't just happening in cities,
it's just happening all over the world.
It's happening to the first Australians.
It's happening in the rainforest and
primitive,
you know,
it's like there is a greed that is
running,
running the world.
Yeah,
it's greed.
There's no empathy and I
alienation happens not only to the
communities that are destroyed but to
the destroyers as well.
I mean,
I just think that the world that is
built up upon the wreckage of these
communities is also a world in which
it's difficult to form community like
new communities.
There are,
I don't know.
I mean,
I've never lived in a,
I don't know.
I think that like this has to go both
ways.
So if I say that,
you know,
I love people and I'm,
I'm for people,
I can't be just for people that I
already agree with,
like this has to go both ways.
You have to,
recently I've been thinking,
okay,
so you need to empower even the very
powerful to be more real with themselves
that actually think about the cost.
The only thing I can think to say is
just empathy.
It does need more empathy.
It's very easy for artists,
a buddy to basically cut themselves off
from all the rest of that humanity and
find some way to people and say like,
oh,
that person is to,
you know,
that's a greedy corporate person,
or that's a this person or that,
you know what I mean?
Like I think it's hard for anyone to to
remind themselves and try to figure out
how to like
not shutoff difficult because part of me
just recoils and kind of wishes that the
world was kind of run by these reptilian
monsters.
The reality is that the human beings are
human beings that are making these
decisions.
And so at the beginning of this
conversation we were talking about,
you know,
whether this kind of grappling between
what we're capable of and what we are
inherent nature is.
And actually what I believe that
inherently we are physiologically
empathic beings.
Right.
That was,
that was a study that that took place
where I learned about this in the
Science Museum in London.
So I know it's true,
right?
So they took two strangers,
put them in a,
in a room,
separated by a glass partition.
And one of them stood on a block of ice
and the temperature of the others,
the temperature of the other person's
feet dropped in response to watching
another human being who they didn't know
stand on a block of ice.
Like our bodies are chained into each
other's.
It's like if I see like I see your wound
on you,
I will recoil,
it will hurt me at some level.
Right.
We have to learn.
People have to learn not to be able to
do that,
you know?
Right.
Yeah.
But so like,
but we've kind of fed this thing about
Humana being this like inherently like
aggressive,
competitive,
selfish.
I don't believe that.
I think that that is something that has
encouraged this kind of myth of the
individual,
which is very helpful for capitalism,
but not very helpful for humanity.
You know?
I mean fierce
to be a pretty strong forest within
humanity as well.
And it seems to me that a lot of this
stuff arises from fear,
right?
I mean,
the primal fear goes all the way back,
right?
I mean,
we're,
we're afraid of death,
you know,
is probably where it begins.
I don't know.
But fear of scarcity,
fear of whatever,
like fear of somebody taking what's
ours.
I don't know.
I think it's probably pretty old.
Yeah,
I'm,
no,
I'm with the you and I think,
I think yes of course.
But like once you are,
sounds so kind of far fetched and also
so easy.
But this is kind of where I'm at at the
minute is if you're,
if you're there,
if you're present with yourself and
suddenly like the,
the worry of things,
the anxiety of things to come.
This is not important because you're
just,
you're just where you are,
you know,
and you can deal with it when it comes.
But I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm a sudden he was about to say
something extremely kind of new agey and
I stopped myself.
I still feel something else.
Okay,
good.
Next subject.
And that's it for this.
Think again,
mixed tape,
which I'm calling the writer's room
gathering some of the most poignant and
interesting advice that I've heard some
writers on writing over the past year.
If you're listening and liking the,
you're probably sick of
hearing me say it,
and I wish that I could personally
remove this message from all the future
episodes of everyone who has gone and
done this.
But at any rate,
I can't.
If you could go and read or review the
show on Itunes,
stitcher,
wherever it is you're listening,
it really doesn't take very long and it
makes a major difference in terms of the
shows sustainability.
We have an amazing season coming up now
that it's fall,
and I hope to see you next week.